[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde est ce que
quelqu'un de la saline au collet haha ça
fait plaisir
bon ben je me présente je m'appelle moi
maître lamouri j'ai 36 ans je suis né en
algérie à l'ouest d'algérie côté de la
frontière marocaine à la wilaya de
tlemcen
j'ai commencé à chanter à l'âge de 5 ans
6 ans parce que j'y compte à l'époque il
ya combien ville et il y avait il n'y
avait pas dit avec les tourne-disques
qui sont à la mode maintenant les postes
cassette egypte et les clips de la télé
qu'il passe la démission qui s'appelle
blé de musique qui s'appelle karim
dynamique
ça va donc j'ai appris j'ai repris donc
pleins pleins d'expérience des changes
en garde les clips à l'époque qu'ils
passent les années puis voilà parce qu'à
l'époque je chante cognac la capitale et
je n'aime pas tant mieux le jeu long
peut-être mes voisins dans notre
immeuble d'un autre quartier à tlemcen
et donc l'âge de 11 ans j après le
synthétiseur après en 2003 je suis venu
en france
j'envie l'âge de 21 ans bien sûr je
connais personne bon quand j'ai tenté ma
chance j'ai je connais personne j'ai
tenté ma chance j'ai fréquenté les
métros parisiens un peu partout vous
connais bien le plan géant garder les
musiciens qui jouent de la musique dans
le métro et le vendent leurs albums et
cetera et cetera
donc j'ai dit je veux être
sam à réfléchir pour jouer dans le métro
j'ai joué dans le métro donc avant j le
sentier celui-là mais enfin je n'avais
pas celui là j'avais l'autre et les
beaucoup trop large
le seul casion à 75 et ça c'est les
mêmes marx et casio est à 78
j'ai fait une reprise de cheb hasni et
après j'ai chanté aussi des reprises de
hotel california les eagles
j'ai chanté aussi là les reprise de
billie jean de michael jackson le jour
de sa mort j'ai regardé dijon est entré
dans le métro je dis qu'est ce qui se
passe ça mais quand jacques c'est
l'élément au caire la maison ici ils
sont pas croisées derrière et puis voilà
et petit à petit j'ai compris comment je
commence à composer mes chansons mes
propres chansons je compose la musique
mais les paroles je suis pas très très
professionnel je pose la musique et moi
je suis pas commun je suis pas un
professionnel je suis pas comme jean
jacques goldman j'avais demandé les
auteurs compositeurs écrivains etc
donc je veux lance la musique que je
veux faire et
[Musique]
donc j'ai choisi un beat numéro des
rythmes 19 et vous allez voir le riddim
1,19 le numéro de 90 71 chez les u19 10
1971 soit une date donnée semble hélas
ça roule
la chanson at elle dit un harami ça veut
dire moi je suis et je veux la salle
écoute
j'espère que ça pour ça vous plaît je
vous remercie où elle obtint
marre de tana saint saulge ariana
détail non
[Musique]
martin
et
[Musique]
oh
je
ad
journée
[Musique]
m
toujours à rien
beynat
[Musique]
par deux
sanaa le soir
à noter
[Musique]
à
à 9,3
[Musique]
moi la fois
on jouera
à
ménat
je
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va
agent topless j'entends rien à ce que ça
va
ça vous plaît merci merci le grand rex
je veux présenter est ce que vous
connaissez la soutiennent coli ok bon on
en a il ya un an on a monté un groupe
qui s'appelle le groupe où cela donc le
groupe hausse là et qui est parti qu'il
est avec nous que l'on compte en montée
en coupe il ya un an on en sortait le 45
tours
c'était le 7 février dernier et puis
voilà j'ai dit le gros de nos deux
groupes aux noms charlie o que la vie
alors gabon à la patrie ona baron rétifs
et la perquisition on avance enfin kim
hye la guitare gibson on à raphaël
guattari applaudi chaleureusement pour
le groupe constat s'il vous plaît et la
chanson ça veut dire rien si ça veut
dire à part toi je vous laisse aller
coûte top six parties
[Musique]
les faits
ono
[Musique]
ça
à
m
[Musique]
paroisse
m
à
[Musique]
ah ah
mais
[Musique]
merci